hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week
on agents of shield we finally got to
meet agent Coulson's cellist so there
were also a ton of awesome comic book
references and if you're not watching
already you should start because there
are only three more episodes left in the
season also in case you missed my
announcement earlier I'm not doing a
bonus Marvel movie video this week just
because I'm starting a special arrow
countdown series tomorrow morning don't
worry though that doesn't mean that I'm
not doing spider-man videos whenever
that movie comes out in the United
States so let's talk some agents of
playing video games seriously who would
not want to join that agency Patton also
will be the perfect supervisor so
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but let's get started
with top five moments here we go number
five Coulson tracks down Marcus Daniels
aka black out from the comic books so
many awesome things about this infamous
list of metahumans that they were
talking about it's really Skye that
calls out the superpowers aspect of it
but pretty much everyone in that fridge
is broken out they don't go too deep
into it but a lot of those people were
actual super villains with real
superpowers Marcus Daniels just happens
to be the freak of the week so in the
comic books that character turns into
the supervillain blackout I was actually
really happy that Coulson you know
explained the mechanism by which he got
his powers usually shows don't go into
that great detail but I feel like it was
a good nerdgasm what is it about the
Marvel Universe and cosmic radiation all
I could think about was the Fantastic
Four but it was a nice payoff to the
Daniels arc that gamma radiation based
tech ended up being the solution also
providing a nice opportunity for a Hulk
shoutout the biggest question that I had
after Daniels explained what happened to
him in the fridge that they experimented
on him was why you know why did they
experiment on him was it just Hydra
scientist conducting research like Baron
von Strucker was doing with Loki's staff
in case you missed it at the end of
Winter Soldier Baron von Strucker had
actually been experimenting on Loki's
staff that's what he was experimenting
on it had the mind gem in it but it's a
whole other story that we can talk about
it in another video sometime on to
number four Patton Oswalt asks everyone
what is in the box every time someone
asks that question I always get a seven
flashback I wonder if there's an outtake
with one of the actors saying there's a
head there's there's a thing in my
mystery box and it's a human head the
chair itself actually just felt like the
ultimate shield geek chair which is kind
of who Patton Oswalt's character
he was like the ultimate Nick Fury
fanboy which actually brings up a really
interesting question that we can debate
in the comments below who do you think
is a bigger Nick Fury fanboy was that
agent Koenig or Agent Coulson my
favorite part of the interrogation scene
was that Doctor Who shout out from
Simmons perfect answer although I feel
like a more honest answer would have
been the doctor you know the doctor is
in the box but if she had said that then
I feel like everyone who does not watch
Doctor Who wouldn't understand what she
was talking about but everyone kind of
understands visually what the TARDIS is
also be sure to let me know in the
comments what will be in your box number
three Ward makes his move on the hard
drive
so I'm actually including him
speechifying his backstory in this it
makes it a little easier to put the
pieces together on how he ended up with
Garrett last week he said that Garrett
rescued him from a bad situation
so I think what ended up happening was
is that Garrett probably killed his
parents and took Ward into training I
think the show will probably explain
this in greater detail once the rest of
the team figures out he's part of Hydra
I was super bummed to see Patton Oswalt
I though I totally loved his character
but he will be avenged number two make
quits Team Coulson and tracks down Maria
hill kind of two big things but really I
don't think anyone thinks that may
actually quit the team she just needs
some time but not only did we get to
meet her mother who I'm guessing was a
spy for the Chinese government or the
Canadian government or maybe someone
else but Mei is going to track down
Maria hill Marvel actually revealed that
she was coming back to the show after a
Winter Soldier premiere so it's not a
huge surprise we knew next week was
gonna be her episode for a while I am
really curious to see how Maria hill
ends up helping team Coulson's because
right now in the story she's working for
Stark Industries trying to do something
positive for Humanity as opposed to you
know spying on everyone in the name of
global security but really we should all
just expect a ton of Awesome Tony Stark
jokes and my number one moment
amy acker debuts as the cellist her part
on the show was really short but my
favorite cellist moment was when she was
explaining how she met Coulson in their
history together I actually expected him
to reveal himself but we can debate on
whether or not he should have in the
comments if you never saw her on any
other Joss Whedon show like angel or
dollhouse she also just starred in his
movie much ado about nothing which Clark
Gregg was
so in that's just an amazing movie all
by itself it's like Whedon verse heaven
seriously you should all watch much to
do about nothing they were kind of vague
on it but that speech from Colson at the
end about telling her whenever the time
was right just leaves the door open for
Amy Acker to come back in the future if
they do get a season two that is but she
could always come back in a movie amy
acker is actually a pretty notable
actress so I don't think it's out of
line to expect that she might be
featured in a small cameo in a movie at
some point but now it's your turn let me
know what was your favorite moment from
the episode you know was it seeing the
super villain blackout seeing him
actually used superpowers or was it just
meeting the cellist for me it really was
seeing the cellist she was such a huge
teaser in The Avengers movie that scene
the payoff was so much fun I'm actually
surprised that the part wasn't a lot
bigger but I think we can pass it to
tumblr to fill in the gaps with
fanfiction overall I gave the episode a
B+ I love the a story you know the
cellist Marcus Daniels story but I felt
like the B story wards Hydra mission
kind of pulled the episode down a little
bit I just don't feel like Chloe Bennet
was able to pull off the double agent
scenes I love her and ward before she
discovered his secret but the way they
edited that Patton Oswalt reveal and the
cella scenes just didn't resonate with
me I just don't think it works as well
when Skye is acting as someone who's not
her own character like Chloe Bennett
acting this guy acting a secret agents
guy trying to deceive Ward I'm not a big
fan of characters acting like other
characters unless your name is Tatiana
maslany and this is orphan black to be
fair though it's super hard to compete
with the cellist she's been such a long
con for the Marvel Universe for so long
that finally getting to meet her was
such a huge payoff and really we've only
been living with Patton Oswalt's
character for one week so I was really
sad that he had to die but his death
just didn't feel like it weighed equally
with her tellus scenes I am kind of
hoping that they eulogize him in some
funny way whenever they try to take down
Ward and Garrett though so let me know
what your final thoughts are on the
episode and big question in the comments
do you think the Coulson should have
revealed himself to the cellist so like
I said because I'm doing special extra
arrow video starting tomorrow morning
I'm not going to be doing a bonus Marvel
movie video this week but I'm still
gonna do a whole bunch of spider-man
stuff whenever that movie comes out in
the u.s. so be sure to subscribe to get
everything right now you can click here
to get that arrow bonus video and you
can
here to get last week's agents of shield
so thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you